good evening uh tonight Douglas rashkoff
delivers the wrote Simon's lecture the
15th in the series that was funded in
2000 by W Mason Smith of the class of
1965 who is with us this evening joined
by his wife
jeie the series brings before the school
speakers from outside the profession to
share their understanding of
interrelatedness for this reason the
series typically but not exclusively
seeks speakers from the social sciences
including anthropologists organizational
theorists philosophers and
sociologists previous wrot Simon's
lecturers have been the
sociologist Richard senet Seth Lao and
saski assassin the architect legislator
and Diplomat Richard SWAT the
Anthropologist arjin
apai and the social critic and
technologist Steph
Johnson last year's wrot Simon's
lecturer was the artist and geographer
Trevor
paglin the wrot Simon's lectures on
named for two of Mason Smith's
classmates one of them Rob Simons died
during the summer after his second year
at our school
as a result of a freak accident caused
by lightning the other David rot a
successful architect practicing in New
York City where he specialized in
affordable housing was killed in
1995 when a gunman went berserk in the
elevator of his office
building tonight's wrot Simon's lecturer
Douglas rashkoff is a 1983 graduate of
Princeton who also holds the MFA in
directing from the California Institute
of the Arts and the PHD in New Media
culture from utre University in the
Netherlands Douglas rashkoff is a media
theorist a television commentator author
and professor of media studies and
digital culture at at cuni
Queens he is recognized as a leading
thinker of the digital age and the
originator of such terms and ideas as
viral media and social
currency his recent book present shock
when everything happens now
2013 describes the constant movement of
information and events flowing from
Twitter smartphones and other daily
routines he is also the author of a
dozen other best-selling books on media
technology and culture including media
virus hidden agendas and popular culture
published in
1996 ecstasy Club one I'm going to read
um a novel published in
1998 program or to be or be program or
be programmed published in
2011 and life Inc how corporatism
conquered the world and how we can take
it back published in 2011 as
well Dr rushkoff is the inaugural winner
of the media ecology association's Neil
Postman award for career achievement in
public intellectual activity he has
served as an adviser to the United
Nations Commission on world culture and
regularly appears on television while
also contributing to the New York Times
the guardian of London and discover
magazine it's my pleasure to welcome
Douglas rashkov to Yale as he delivers
the root Simon's lecture chyros Kronos
time and space designing for humans in
the digital world Douglas
roskov thanks it's it's to be here a
little scary to be here after hearing
the names of others who've uh who've
done this lecture but uh this thing
doesn't actually do anything oh well I
had this great device I'm not I'm
supposed to be a tech person but that
that supposed to time you down for like
you know a one hour talk and all but you
can it doesn't
uh okay oh I know it did oh it did after
an hour I will I will replace the
machine and yank you off the
platform called the dean they had they
have an app they know what I'm going to
the app people know what I'm going to
say about them so they're already uh
they've algorithmically uh deduced their
their
Rebellion um yeah I I uh it was
interesting listening to to myself being
described I definitely mix the uh the
the high with the low and sometimes get
confused about which is which but um in
some ways that's a good thing I mean for
me H you know the the the concepts of of
you know High futin Greek ideals like
Kronos and chyros I mean they
uh occurred to me when I was watching
The Real Housewives of Orange County
with my wife I mean she that's what she
watches and I'm married to her so that's
what I watch and uh you know and I watch
these shows as a media theorist you know
I like to think from this higher level
of uh cultural observation um but what
what amazed me over the the year or so I
watched this show was how many um
Communications difficulties these women
had right I watch it as a communication
theorist so why would communication
break down between these women and I use
all the the kind of classical filters
that we have well they're from the same
socioeconomic group they speak the same
language you know they look the same
they have the same values they're in the
same room they're up close they're face
to face why should there be so many
Communications lapses and then what I
realized was that these women have so
much plastic surgery and so much Botox
in their faces that they're paralyzed
right they can't make facial expressions
that are consonant with the things that
they're saying so you'll see one of them
say you know my my daughter's going in
for uh cancer testing tomorrow and the
other one says oh I'm so sorry to hear
that you know because she can't say it
any other way and then they show the
first one they'll interview her off to
the side and she'll say oh you she
doesn't care at all about my daughter
she was smiling through the the whole
thing she doesn't care she wasn't they
can't connect and I realized that this
these women were were really falling
prey to the the the technological
problem that I think that we as a
society are are are falling victim to
and that's that they're they're using
technology to try to lock down time
rather than to enter the moment that
they're in right so these women have
used Botox and plastic surgery to try to
lock chronological time at age
29 and in doing so they've made
themselves unavailable to the actual
moment that they're in in the room with
the other person right and that there's
no way to avoid that trade-off once you
start to cling to that moment and that's
as I understand it that's what the
ancient Greek Notions of Kronos and
chyros are really about Kronos is time
on the clock right what time did you
crash the car
crash the car at 4:01 p.m. that you know
what time do you tell Dad that you
crashed the car right 417 517 you tell
Dad you crash the car after he's had his
drink and before he's opened the bills
right it's not a time on the clock but a
human time right so the time on the
clock is Kronos that human time that
only we can understand really through
interpretation through feeling through
experience is chyros so these women have
have surrendered the chyos of their
intimate moments to the Kronos of their
ideas about what age they should try to
be and this is what we've done I would
argue this is what we've done with
technology right when I first
encountered the internet I saw it as
something that was going to make more
time right I graduated college 1983 this
was the height of the slacker era for
those of you that missed it the whole
point of slack wasn't just to be lazy it
was to have time to do the things you
wanted to do you know you watch Rick
linkletter's movie slacker and you'll
see these people are sitting and talking
dereda and philosophy they're it's not
that they're not working they're just
not working at boring die Yuppy scum
sorts of jobs right they're working in
things that they actually care about so
creating more slack creating more
time is a way to get more time to do the
things you actually want to do so when
we first had the internet even before
the internet I was on a Bulet board that
was called the well the whole earth
electronic link and it was this
asynchronous conversation that we had
online with one another and the beauty
of an asynchronous conversation is you
would you would I mean this was an old
internet that most of you are too young
to remember but you you would turn on
your computer you would log into a
telnet program you would plug the
computer into this device called a modem
that would hook it up to a phone line
you would dial up to a server you would
download the conversation to your
computer you would disconnect from the
modem you would read the conversation
that's happening between these people
that you want to be involved with right
and you could take a day an hour as long
as you want reading their conversation
and then you would think how do I want
to contribute to this conversation what
do I want to say how do I want to
present myself and you would take hours
to create this perfect screens siiz
paragraph that really encapsulates how
you feel about something or overnight
it's kind of like chess by mail or
something you'd really take your time it
when you had it just right you plug back
in upload it to the thing to the
conversation and then wait and see how
people reacted to what you said right so
the internet was a place where we
actually sounded smarter than we do in
real life imagine that the internet was
a place where people sounded smarter
than they do in real life right you you
sounded like Christopher Hitchens just
brilliant it was
great and now what we did you know and
we can argue as to why we did this I
mean the when the internet was
discovered uh was was discovered by
business it was seen as potentially the
salvation of the dying NASDAQ Stock
Exchange you know that this this rather
than just being this uh source of uh
people watching less television which is
what it started out as people were
afraid the internet was going to kill
business families the average Internet
connected family in 1993 was watching
nine hours less commercial television
per week but this was a nightmare right
but when we realize that the internet
could be used to extract value and money
from people well we took the internet
and turned it from this nice
asynchronous device into an alwayson
device it's strapped to your body that
vibrates every time somebody wants to
ping you or update you or update
themselves or send you a picture of this
we live in a state of of Perpetual
emergency Interruption that used to be
endured only by you know 911 operators
or air traffic controllers and they only
did it 4 hours at a time they got paid
for it and they took drugs to amarate
the symptoms of it we just do it as the
way of life right so what did we do we
took an asynchronous technology that was
actually creating time for us and turned
it into something that takes time from
us right it puts us in this what I'm
calling present shock this sense of
Perpetual present what's now what's now
what's now you know the state of
constant Interruption now the only
interruptions in media that I knew
growing up was I remember when Martin
Luther King got shot they interrupted
the television broadcast right because
someone shot or Wallace was shot I
remember that one too something big when
did they when did they those of you who
are old like me when did they interrupt
a phone call the operator would break in
why because Grandma's dying right
Grandma's dying and they would cut in
the operator would say I'm sorry I have
an emergency
call now you get call waiting in every
call that you do right so what's that
saying to your body what's that saying
to your psyche all the time Grandma's
dying Grandma's dying Grandma's dying
Grandma's dying as if it matters
Grandma's not not dying somebody tweet
it right why is that worth taking you
out of the stream that you're actually
in is I mean it's there later this is
this is what's called an asynchronous
medium but we're using it as if it were
an always on synchronous medium and we
look at our Twitter feeds and our
Facebook feeds as if we have to catch up
with the moment I'm always behind I
can't catch up to that no this is trying
to catch up with you you're living in
real life in the actual moment of the
present and these things are trying to
catch up with you trying to distract to
distract you from what you're
doing and we started to talk about time
human time I remember in 1994 Wired
Magazine declared that we're living in
an attention economy right the the the
real estate online is infinite right
there's this you can you can make as M
essentially infinite you can put as much
server space out there and keep putting
stuff in websites the thing that they
realized was finite was human attention
so they started talking about human
attention they came up with a metric for
it they call it eyeball
hours I don't know if they still use
that today eyeball hours are the amount
of hours that someone's eyeballs can be
on your website or in your application
and the object of the game the thing
that started to teach was how to make
websites sticky sticky was what we
wanted them to be so you get stuck to it
they even had an ad for one uh company
called real media that showed people
stuck on a piece of fly paper and
there's the slogan was um nothing
attracts like real media you know being
stuck on fly paper is not attraction
right that's that's imprisonment it's a
bad thing not a good
thing but that's the direction we went
with it so that was going on this state
of uh sort of uh of digital Interruption
that I'm calling present shock this uh
uh this misapplication of an
asynchronous technology turning it into
a synchronous one and giving us
asynchronous uh asynchronous lives that
happened at the same time that I believe
we we shifted from a forward leaning
speculative Society to a presentist
society now I called that book pres
shock because you know I was a my
parents had I don't know how many copies
of Future Shock in their house it was
this giant bestseller and it really was
a bestseller not because people were
reading it it was more like a petti kind
of a book you know people just had it
around it was too long for people to
really read they didn't read then either
but it was around right people read the
introduction and thematically it it was
consonant with a society that was
leaning forward leaning towards the
Millennium all the shows we watched on
in and the evening television were like
on the 21st century we watched things
about monals and going we thought we
were going to have jetpacks and live on
Mars and colonize the moon there was a
very futury quality to America at the
end of the 20th century and it really
started to reach a peak with the do com
Boom the idea of the long boom everyone
thought we can speculate and grow
forever that right over at at Harvard
they were MIT they were saying this is
it we're going to have infinite growth
that like the just like the universe can
expand forever so too can the economy
it's going to grow in an unbounded
fashion forever and the internet's going
to allow it's just going to go go
go right that was going on at the same
time that we were just even even uh uh
numerically moving towards this thing
this
Y2K and that's why we had these great
fantasies the Y2K bug you remember that
people thought that when the clocks
changed from 1999 to 2000 that all the
computers were going to break because
they didn't know how to do four digigit
years km Airlines grounded their Fleet
because they thought planes were going
to fall out of the sky when they were
unable to compute what happened nobody
knew there was this sort of harmonic
convergence year 2012 transhumanist
what's going to happen leaning forward
toward the year 2000 of NASDAQ Stock
Exchange got past 5,000 oh my God then
the year 2000 happened and people were
like well now
what and now what really means now what
right so we went from a speculative
forward leaning 1990s here it comes the
Millennium end of Messiah God knows
what you know and we could talk about
the media that allowed that to happen
that's really a it's a it's an artifact
of text and contracts and the Covenant
and it's as a media theorist I see it
all as the age of print and broadcast
finally ending but that's kind of
another conversation for for our
purposes as a society we went from this
forward-leaning one to one that was in
the present then 911 happens which is
another huge discontinuity as big for us
as the JFK assassination was for our
parents this sort of moment of
discontinuity that again was covered by
media in a way and we saw it from all
angles the same way we looked at at
Kennedy kind of
sequentially these two things combine to
put us our society in a state of what
I'm calling present shop and I think
it's both uh scary but ultimately a
great opportunity to reconnect to chyros
to human time which is not inaccessible
to us it's just uh a little distant from
the way we think about things think of
chyros as as uh laziness or soft or
somehow um disengaged when I'm arguing
that it's in some ways more engaged but
these two factors our our uh uh Mis
misapplication of digital technology
temporary and our shift from a uh 1900s
to 2000s
Society led to this this moment this
this this gaping kind of uh uh uh abys
this this an existential pause and as
you know if you're on in a treadmill
Society the last thing you want people
to do is pause right they can't pause
because when you pause uh oh they're
going to people are going to start
thinking and that's that's going to be
weird they're going to start wondering
why am I working what am I doing what is
this money what is this thing they're
going to start re-evaluating no thinking
just
go right
so the first casualty of this new kind
of presentism I think was narrative and
what I call narrative collapse is the
the death of the traditional St we could
even use this actually it's like a real
classroom I mean remember we learned
this this is narrative that that's what
Aristotle figured out about the great
Greek
tragedy and they see it up there why you
raise the screen it's like
that if you can let's do
it
[Music]
cool so we learned this was
narrative right the you create a
character the audience likes that
character makes a series of choices that
puts him into danger the audience
follows vicariously up the incline plane
of tension until they can't take it
anymore and then up
here we have you know the recognition
and reversal and then crisis
Climax and relief right so it's crisis
climax sleep the sort of male orgasm
curve of narrative
Theory right for a male for a male
Millennium or
two right now what happens when you have
uh uh you know remote control or any
kind of digital device to deconstruct
this thing it stops working the same way
right if I'm going up the incline plane
of tension especially if I'm watching a
30-second advertisement about some kid
who's got a zit and she might not get
get to go to the prom because it's a
thing and she's popping she's doing all
this bad stuff we're going up the
incline pain of tension watching her
make this zit get worse and
worse if my father's watching this
commercial he's got to sit there if he
wants to change the channel and get away
from that story he's got to get up off
the Lazy Boy chair walk up to the
television turn there was a dial turn
the dial and adjust the rabbit ears
which let the that used to come in
through the air into it was a whole
thing adjust the rabbit ears and then
sit back down in his chair go pop right
there like 50 calories of human effort
to get out of this incline attention or
he could just accept 10 12 calories of
anxiety until he gets the clear aill the
oxy 5 or whatever it is it's going to
let him out of the out of the anxiety
what's he going to pick you know the
path of least resistance I'll take my
anxiety but a kid with a remote control
watching that same commercial makes the
same calculation 0.001 calories of
effort and I'm out of that imposed state
of anxiety right so instead of this
they're they're going to get that you
know they're going to jump on to the
game and then go on to the cartoon and
then go on here and come back here after
this commercial's over I mean watch
yourself or someone watching television
with a remote control right they're no
longer watching television they're
watching the television right they're
outside the original context of the TV
right they're watching the TV and
watching what's on tonight and they
manage you manage you always do you get
back to Law and Order before they figure
you get there you know what I mean you
get to the game you get to this you see
what you need to see but you're no
longer seeing it from within the context
of the narrative you're seeing it from
outside but that's why we started to
make narrative that no longer follows
this rule or if it does it follows these
rules as an almost a little wink and a
nod to traditional narrative you look at
The Simpsons which has been around what
26 years now or something like that what
is The Simpsons was the first show that
said this is less important to us than
something else right what's happening in
The Simpsons is a series of connections
the object of the game watching The
Simpsons is to figure out what are they
starzing here what are they sterzing
there oh I remember that commercial oh
that's an Alro Hitchcock movie oh this
is that oh this is that so the reward
that you're getting is not this big
final reward at the end you're getting
this series of little connections that
you make oh I got that oh I got that oh
I got that we don't really care if Homer
Simpson makes it out of the power plant
before it explodes and even if he
doesn't he'll be back next week what we
care about instead are these little
moments and if you look at the media
that was coming out right around that
time in Mystery Science Theater was what
do I get this joke do I get that joke
what are they they're making Andrew
Lloyd Weber jokes in a science fiction B
movie and I'm supposed to get that right
but when I do what do I get I get that
sense of reward the sense of now I'm
recognizing patterns in a seemingly
random sea of media now I'm making the
connections I'm seeing these things you
know beas and but head all of these
shows whenever you see a screen within a
screen a a kind of a South Park like
media within media Within media you
realize that the pleasure is no longer
this linear pleasure but the sense of uh
uh being able to frame something and
reframe and recontextualize it it's that
sense of of
recapitulation so you look at the shows
that we've got now in an atemporal
landscape you look at a what's a biggy
like a A Game of
Thrones right no one really cares who's
going to win the throne you don't want
it to get there Game of Thrones is
structured more like a fantasy
roleplaying game game even the opening
credits of Game of Thrones what are you
doing you're going over the map of the
city of the of the whole place as if it
were a a game of Dungeons and Dragons
there's too many characters you'd like
too many of them you you don't want it
to get to the place where someone wins
the throne because then the game is over
right so we move you know not just in
media but even in gaming we move from
kind of Winner Takes all agonistic play
between teams where winning the game
means ending the game to much more of an
open uh infinite game as as James
carswood put it which is a great little
book on on this an infinite game where
you don't want to win because that would
end the play instead the object of the
game is to see how long can we keep this
game
going now you can argue oh that's bad
these are bad values and of course
parents were all upset about these kinds
of games but what's important about the
values of these games is that they're
not looking for finality it's not not
about getting to the apocalypse or to
the end and winning it's about M it's
about maintenance it's about
sustainability it's about how long can
we keep this going which to my mind is a
much more pertinent question to us as a
society now how long can we keep this
thing going rather than how do we get to
win because what is even what is even
winning so as you move from this
narrative culture into a video game like
culture we move instead of watching
someone make a series of choices and
vicariously live or die through him we
are now in first person right making the
choices ourselves so the experience both
culturally and and in this metaphor I'm
using of a video game is now we have the
experience of moving from choice to
choice to choice to
choice right and in the first person
it's me making these choices it's why
the kids wear those little bracelets now
that the the Christian kids that what
would Jesus do what is that it's it's as
clear an example of a church moving from
Jesus died for your sins to what would
Jesus do this is the way you're going to
be Christian now is through your series
of choices in this moment I'm not saying
it's good or bad I'm just saying it's
different right it shifted to something
else now what we
did with digital technology one of the
mistakes we made is we told people well
yeah we're moving from choice to choice
to choice to choice but what digital
technology will tell you now is you can
choose both you don't have to choose
this or that you can do both at the same
time right you can tweet while you
Facebook while you're sitting in your
class right you can multitest you can
maintain just like a computer chip you
can put some of your stuff in this piece
of memory and some task here and some
task there and some task there and let
them all operate in a parallel
processing way and then they'll come
back to your brain doesn't work like
that it turns out we only really have
one Consciousness at a time and what can
do we can shift I can do Twitter then I
can do Facebook then I can do Twitter
then I can do Facebook then I can listen
to the teacher then I can do Twitter
then I can do Facebook or is it Twitter
then Facebook
sorry oops you know that really happens
too and that's when you that's when you
realize what happens when you multitask
with every experiment that we've done on
multitasking with kids even at Stamford
the the computer science people who
really believe they're great at
multitasking objectively they always
stink at it even when subjectively they
think they've gotten more done
objectively they they're less accurate
they're slower they have a lower volume
of stuff that's done and it's not like
we're going to develop some super
multitasking ability you know people
evolve really slow you know it's not
it's like like the multitasking
hemisphere of the brain needs to be lit
up you know and Google's going to write
a program that's going to suddenly make
that it doesn't really work like that
that's not unfortunately that's not
science so instead we tell ourselves and
this is what I call dig ofren that we
can be in more than one place at the
same time the problem with digital
technology is never that we're being
overwhelmed with data they used to say
it was a information overload would be
the big problem I've never experienced
information overload because I can only
see so much information at a time right
there's a ton of information but I'm
still reading at around 5600 bot I guess
or 24 I don't know there's it's that's
that's not the problem the problem is
having more than one instance of myself
operating simultaneously but there's my
Facebook self over over there God knows
what's happening on my Twitter self my
email inbox is filling up with stuff
Mark Zuckerberg might be advertising
with my image right now something that
he knows that I might want
someday right there's all these
different selves I have to maintain and
worry about because they're operating
even though I only have one
Consciousness know it's why drone Pilots
it turns out you know drone Pilots
experience higher levels of
post-traumatic stress disorder than real
Pilots now why is that you know and I
started looking I spent some time with
them the reason why is because they're
dropping bombs on people from their
their hanger in Nevada all day long then
they get in a car drive home and have
dinner with their wife and kids oh how
is second grade today honey you know
it's that sense of dis they're in more
than one place they're not on the war
zone the ones who are in war they go
back to a bar with other Pilots at least
and have a drink and share their
experience rather than than being
literally in Two Worlds at the same time
and the reason why we don't get this is
because the the digital media
environment is convincing us that time
is somehow generic that time is Kronos
that this time and that time and that
time are all just the same so you can
just go from now there's the war part
now there's the driving part now there's
the hug my uh second grader part and it
doesn't really work like that time it
turns out is not generic at all you know
what we're discovering now in in even in
uh Neuroscience this should be
interesting to you guys is that over the
course of a of a of a lunar cycle
people's neurochemistry changes in the
first week of a new moon people tend to
be dominated by a cetl choline and the
second week by serotonin the third week
by dopamine the fourth week by
norepinephrine it's like well what does
that mean if everybody's in serotonin
week and now everybody's in
norepinephrine week and now everybody's
in acetylcholine week means different
weeks are actually better for different
things you ever have a week where you
just can't get work done it's probably
dopamine week that's supposed to be
party week not get work done we you know
norp andrine week that's the fighter
flight figh ORF flight uh
neurotransmitter so that's really good
when you're going to do like a a you
know just big you know Mile High
organizational systemic kinds of stuff
as compared to the uh uh serotonin week
which is going to be much more textural
on the ground what am I actually where I
where are we going if you want
understood that if we understood that
time is even just not generic we would
start to understand oh it's more like a
landscape than it is this uh than it is
a piece of technology you know because
we're not we are not generic we have
nooks and crannies and moods and things
that we
change you know another another uh
feature of this presti world I this this
this uh disconnect between uh the kind
of time we live and the kind of time
we're trying to live is something I call
overwinding which is where we try to
squish really wide periods of time into
the wrong time scales you know it's the
the Wall Street equivalent where someone
you know you don't just buy a stock now
because you're not going to buy a stock
and then wait a year and see if it went
up or down right the day that Facebook
went public people bought the stock and
they were angry 10 minutes later that it
hadn't gone up because they think
they're going to make money on the trade
itself I want to make money by buying
the I got to wait wait a month to see if
it goes up so if you don't want to wait
the month what do you do you buy a
derivative because now you can buy the
stock a month from now now so you squish
that 30 days if that's not enough you
could buy the derivative 30 days from
now and squish that or buy the
derivative of the derivative of the
derivative 30 days so all you're doing
is taking all these big big pieces of
time and compressing them again and
again and again and we're so much more
committed to that you know there's 80
times more derivative trading than there
is real trading derivative trading got
so big the D rtiv exchange bought the
New York Stock Exchange you know that
the New York Stock Exchange was
purchased and consumed by its own
abstraction what kind of a world is that
that is an overwhelmed
world even Facebook does this to you you
know Facebook it's it's a temporal
compression of your past and your future
there's people from fifth grade that
I've spent 40 years getting away from
who now show up and want to be my friend
today right up there with all my other
friends compressing all that time I've
lived and loved to be that distant is
now swished right back up into the
present meanwhile Mark Zuckerberg is
sending me advertisements using big data
from the future I don't yet know I'm
going to have right he knows if I'm
going to turn gay or get divorced or get
cancer or have a rectile dysfunction
before I
do or his algorithm certainly so that
future is now being pushed back in me
too so I can't just be here now in any
way right there's my past there's my
future and where is me you know where is
me wo is
me the
the the other great mistake we make is
something I've been calling fractal NOA
which is uh kind of I think we owe it to
to Gregory baton and me and the people
who really looked at systems theory as U
as a means of control rather than as a
means of pattern recognition and and
what we've what we've done is
uh how to say it in a fast way you know
we've gone in some ways it's great we've
gone from a command and control
understanding of the world to one that's
much more iterative and we understand we
understand feedback and iteration but we
uh don't really know how to see it how
to listen to it so a uh what would be an
example a company sends out a tweet that
ends up going but bad on them right they
send a tweet that turns out is racist or
they didn't realize it said something
uhoh you can't take it back and now all
the other stuff's coming at them all the
angry tweets all this stuff they they
can no longer tell then as they try to
fix the situation they can't tell what
what is responding to what they've put
out and what's responding to something
else that's out there they can no longer
parse the difference between the
feedback and the iteration right so
they're basically stuck in when you take
a microphone and stick it in the speaker
and you get that Screech because you
just get a loop but they can't they
can't break it open anymore you know so
we have uh and you guys work with
fractals do you Architects still work
with fractals I did the one other talk I
did with architect it was at Reba in
London and I real I had done a home
improvement project I had done more
architecture than any of these people
they they cuz actually just taking wood
and putting the thing together you know
or the or the sua and the and the but
they were all they were all into uh they
were all into fractals and you know the
beauty of fractals is that you can look
at one little you zoom into one little
part of a fractal and it kind of
reflects a larger piece you know it's
it's there self- similar right this is a
little bit like that it's a little bit
like that they're really good and
they're fun for pattern recognition the
problem is when you look at a fractal or
a a a self- similar system and say not
this is a lot like that but this is that
right this is that and that is this as
above so below oh Plankton do this
therefore people do that therefore the
universe does that it's like wait a
minute you're going crazy here right and
then you listen you know listen to
conspiracy radio you know when something
happens say oh that's because the harp
station in Alaska they created a tsunami
in Japan because they wouldn't sign the
trade agreement on that and American
Gold is going to go off the thing this
is what happens when you no longer have
any of this when you no longer have
linear cause and effect logic to
understand the world you try to
understand it in a snapshot moment right
how are we going to understand 911 not
the history of what we did with al-
Qaeda and Afghanistan no we're going to
understand Al Qaeda by taking a snapshot
of the moment there's the plane there's
a this there's a person there's a that
there's a that if you have to make sense
of things by drawing lines between stuff
in the moment you're going to draw too
many lines but you're going to draw
connections between things because
you've missed an entire Dimension you
know that's fractal noia it's where you
get into that paranoid State because you
need to make sense of something you know
and finally what happens to us is what I
call Apocalypto know when you live in a
world that's in the present you start
aching for a conclusion when is this
going to end what's going to happen
where is it all going you know when you
even talk to the guys who are supposed
to be the most atheist of our scientists
and and computer scientists and all
they're all big in the singularity now
it's like oh there's no God there's no
purpose there's no nothing but computer
technology is striving towards greater
States Of Consciousness and will soon
reach it and then it will manifest the
the uh the natural order of the universe
and human beings can Retreat you know
into the uh a subordinate role and keep
people around at least in so far as they
keep the machines uh going because
they're going to they're going to take
take on from us you know they create a
story that our universe is information
striving towards greater states of
complexity so information first it uses
atoms then molecules and cells and
organisms and then maybe cultures and
now computers so it will it will keep
going until we get to the uh the the
great Omega point which is basically
good oldfashioned Christian Aristotelian
story arc overlaid on something that
doesn't really follow that at all or it
doesn't have to I suppose we can make it
but it's deeply anti-human in spirit
you know which is why so much of what we
see so much of our future casting now
has humans and just the worst
predicaments and roles you know I watch
I watch with all you guys I watch all
the zombie shows the zombie shows and
zombie movies and you know it's
interesting you know I I don't think we
watch it for fear I think we watch it as
a form of uh of Desire I think we long
to be I mean at least in the Zombie
World your phone's not buzzing your boss
isn't ask you don't have to earn money
you're not going to get tax audited in
the in the Zombie World right you're
just going to sit on a mountain they
move slow you got a shotgun you got your
family you get some food you're getting
laid you kill some things this is this
is good right I think we look at it like
that not the fast moving zombie one
those are kind of
scary the slow ones it's it's it's kind
of cool but what are the zombies really
saying what is a zombie show about
finally thematically what it's about is
is there a difference between me and the
zombie that's why you have so many
everyone you've got to have one where
you look at the zombie and the zombie is
looking at you and the character has to
think what really makes me different
from them I kill right I kill to eat you
know I try to protect myself and then
the blood happens I'll even kill someone
I know if I have
to we are not zombies we are humans
right but these shows just like
Singularity people
have a an inability to appreciate the
human you know they are they are
anti-human and when I tell them this you
know when I tell my Singularity friends
my great peers in the New Media thinkery
profession they say oh rushka you just
say that because you're
human like it's
hubis it's like well yeah I'm a
human I am on team human and I'm that's
not going to be I refuse I'm ashamed of
so much else I refuse to be ashamed of
my Humanity itself yes I'm going to be a
humanist in that sense I'm going to use
humanism as my uh uh value system but
this anti-humanism it just dovetails
just a little bit too conveniently with
this with the the Industrial Age
corporate model that we're using to
develop our technology it's just a
little bit too convenient I mean because
industrialism more than anything was
about removing human beings from the
equation of
Commerce know we had before
industrialism in the late Middle Ages
the age of cathedrals you guys like
Cathedrals the age of cathedrals was a
peer-to-peer Economy based in the bizaar
right feudalism had ended they had the
Crusades a bunch of people came back
with all different weird stuff
technology developed we had the most the
most prosperous
time in Europe really women were taller
in late medieval Europe than they were
at any time until the 1980s in England
because people were having five meals a
day they're working three days a week
and it's because they had a peer-to-peer
economy they had local currencies all
these things that we don't really need
to talk about exactly now but they
weren't living in a system that was that
was designed to extract value from them
they were in a system where they were
exchanging value with each other as they
needed it in order to in order to
survive and the two things that taken
from them was one their right to do
peer-to-peer trade next when we got the
chartered monopolies that got exclusive
Province over a particular industry
right so instead of me buying shoes from
you now I have to buy them from the shoe
official shoe factory instead of you
being a shoe maker now you are an
employee of the shoe factory right and
the second thing they came up with was
Central currency so instead of us using
Market money to trade with one another
money that's really biased towards
circulation toward transaction we're
going to use borrowed currency that's
biased towards you know speculation and
and growth of capital that's very clever
what else would you do if you were an
aristoc if you were an aristocrat who
was looking at a rising peer-to-peer
culture that was growing less and less
dependent on you right you'd come up
with a money a money system that you
made their money's illegal so now they
have to borrow your money and pay you
back interest to use it good one right
that was clever and the second was the
only companies that can be in business
bus are companies that I have a piece of
that I can invest in and this was sort
of the beginning of the the death grip
between uh uh government and uh and
Industry and whether you're talking
communism or capitalism it's the same
problem it's always the the two are
exactly
together so
industrialism strategy though was to
remove that face-to-face humanness from
business that was the point so instead
of you being a skilled Shoemaker I don't
want a skilled Shoemaker in my in my
factory I want someone I can go to the
Home Depot parking lot get some illegal
immigrant bring him in and train him in
15 minutes to bang something in a shoe
because that guy can't ask for more
money you
can right so in order to make industry
work we need to disconnect workers from
the value that they could bring from
their actual competency which is a a
very dangerous game that we played you
know and the second thing we need to do
is now disconnect the seller from the
buyer so instead of me buying oats from
Robert the oat seller in my town it's
going to come in a plane brown box from
2,000 miles away you know and this is
where people like me came in they hired
people like me to say what can we do to
this brown box to make people like it as
much as they like Robert I said well
I've done some anthropological analysis
and Americans really like Quakers
so put a picture of a Quaker on the
box and then when it gets there people
are going to like like that and like it
more than him more than him well I got
it I'll invent radio and television
which will give you a way to broadcast
the image of that Quaker to that person
before he even sees it all these great
28c commercials of of Quakers doing
great things and making nice oats so
when that box does arrive he's going to
go oh the Quaker Quaker plus I don't
know have to deal with Robert anymore
you oh
people right so we move we remove the
human element from consumption and from
production no and that's really what
what the Industrial Age was about was
about this removal of humans you look
think about the um uh remember the
Crystal Palace the the Victorian
exhibition of when was that 18 51
51 what were people looking at they were
looking at the machines at the Looms at
the stuff right they were it was about
the technology this is what's being this
is what we've this is what we've
developed this is how we've taken over
the world this is what we've done right
through to the World's Fair where people
are being conveyed through things you
can just touch a button in this and
here's a nice robot who's going to help
you right through to CES or apple world
today which is about the stuff never the
human creativity you or look at um an
old invention like the dumb waiter what
was the dumb waiter for was it to make
it easier for slaves to get the food up
no it was to make it so that Thomas
Jefferson didn't need to see the sweaty
slave who made the food you just it's
invisible just pull the thing food right
it's like a Star Trek replicator there's
no person there there's nothing
happening there the same as with when we
get Amazon drones you don't even not
even going to have to see the the the
guy dressed in brown who comes with the
package at the door you just going to be
a little a little drone flight machine
whatever they are drone plane and Amazon
Turks will do your work for you right
advertising which we already saw how it
disconnects people it how it replaces
human- to Human Relationships that that
becomes big data and recommendation
engines right so again you don't have to
you don't have to use anything uh uh
interpersonal and the equivalent of the
chartered monopolies of that period are
the platform monopolies of this period
you know Uber would be a great thing if
the cabbies owned Uber you know but Uber
is not a great thing when it's got $15
billion of capital to pay back how do
you pay back $15 billion of capital on
cab drivers they don't there's not
enough money in that right the only way
you do that is by flipping into another
vertical into another vertical into
another vertical so what you need to do
is not just have a successful
sustainable company you need to have a
company that can grow at least at the
rate of interest but preferably at the
rate of the capital that they've been
given you know and people say oh don't
worry there's a long tail that's going
to take care of everybody and we all
know the long tail doesn't actually work
that what we end up with with all of our
access to music and video and anyone can
make anything with their device what we
end up with is a world where there's
fewer stars on the top and more
completely unpaid people on the bottom
that the extremes the exacerbation the
division of wealth and prosperity in the
Arts in pretty much every field is
exacerbated by this access because we're
using platform monopolies to do it you
know so the internet is a beautiful
possibility but not when we surrender
its programming that's what program orb
program meant not when we surrender its
programming to people who don't really
have our best interest at heart but
really just need to hit a home run for
the VC that's given them 15 million
bucks when they're 20 years old to leave
college and make this
company you know what we've forgotten is
and you know and Adam Smith told us this
you know this is classical economics
we've forgotten this takes three there
are three factors of production land
labor and capital right and capital is
the only one that feels perfectly
consonant with the digital technology
because capital is just sort of its
numbers and it can expand and it can
grow so digital technology is great for
amplifying the importance of capital in
the equation but it's really also great
at diminishing the importance of the
people and the places the actual place
that things come from now it doesn't
work well for bounded economies and only
a bounded economy can promote Prosperity
between people a bounded economy you can
get some circulation of capital moving
around of currency moving as opposed to
unbounded investment where we're going
to be everything to everyone we're just
going to keep growing infinitely you
know we're going to do this and win
right as opposed to do something else do
something more uh uh more chyos
like so yeah I think that the easiest
way to uh to design and build in such an
environment in a digital media
environment that is going to be biased
we can even say intrinsically because of
how digital technology works it's going
to be biased against human interests and
human scale right is to emphasize human
interest and human scale in everything
we do you know and this is not
regressive this is not uh Lite or
anti-technology know if anything I would
argue my my Singularity peers you know
the ones who are you know and getting
employed a immediately by Google when
they come out of the closet as a let's
build a cathedral for the consciousness
of the computer and I mean they they go
there you know the the the Turing on
acid uh uh technologists of
today they are the
reactionaries right they are trying to
use digital technology to pump another
round of steroids into a a traditional
and extractive form of
colonial corporatism
you know and I'm asking that we that we
think Beyond this unacknowledged
operating system you know if you lived
in a world where every computer was a
Macintosh you wouldn't know that such a
thing as an operating system existed you
would think that's just
computer know and I feel like that's our
problem right now as we as we uh accept
the ground rues the tenants the the
presumptions of a a uh a generic digital
economy as our rule set we end up uh
limiting our development we end up
limiting our design to things that
support that rather than supporting one
another the other people right in the
room so what what I would ask we do and
and hopefully in the next uh 12
and a half minutes discuss is whether we
can transcend this uh sort of limited
notion of of prosp Prosperity before we
start talking about
transcending uh Humanity altogether
because I'm I'm I'm going to be a human
for the rest of my
life uh and I think most of you are too
I would bet um nothing wrong with
augmenting your intelligence and using
technology to expand what it means to be
human but it's very different for humans
to become you know just as we were kind
of surval to an economic model it would
be an equally or perhaps more
disastrous uh uh choice for us to uh
surrender ourselves to a digitally
enhanced version of that system because
that one's going to be really uh much
much harder to stop you know the
Technologies we're building today are
not Industrial Age Technologies robotics
genomics uh Nano and digital are
different kinds of technologies that
when you set them in motion they evolve
themselves they keep going they act as
if they were preserving themselves they
modify themselves over time so what we
program into them now um will come back
around at us again not karmically weirdo
spiritually but really you know you
watch a program that you that you design
and watch what it does and you'll see oh
it has different values than I do so we
have to get better at programming those
in but we also have to get better at
choosing to program them in in the first
place rather than just jumping you know
it's hard I know you do all this stuff
and daddy comes and says oh I'm going to
reward you for what you did you know
when we little hacker people who loveed
the internet in the early days no one
believed us people used to laugh I got
laughed out of editors offices for
suggesting that they'd be using email
Someday My First book on the internet
got cancelled in 1992 because they
thought the net would be over by 1993
when the book was scheduled to come out
they thought it was like CB radio some
trucker trucker
bad it's
bizarre but um but it's not I I don't
feel like we're we're you know late late
in this game at all and I do believe we
can bring a uh a consciousness of the
real of the real time and place in which
people live it's easier than thinking
about people is to think about human
scale you know what is the scale at
which I actually physically move what is
the scale in which I temporally exist
and then you start to get the beginning
oh I have a message for you from
Barcelona I'll end with this I went to
Barcelona after I found out I was doing
this and I I went with a a barcelonan
radical and saw the um you know the
Gaudi Cathedral thing yeah duh um course
the the G thing and we're looking at it
and there were all these cranes around
it and he and he said you know just
lately they started to work on this
thing way way too
fast and I really took that with me as
if he saw a change that they decided
they want to get it done so now they're
bringing in the cranes and he's like now
it's over the the cathedral the thing
what it actually represented to him was
gone because it had left the scale at
which it was functioning at which it was
functioning in that Community for the
sort of industrial need to let's finish
this thing and get the tourists here and
save the economy and do all that he's
like ah another thing another one
gone okay so I wanted to make sure you
had that message in case there's
something you're supposed to be to do
about it as architect people right you
make a call right okay so do you guys
have thoughts questions you want to
let's have a a
conversation or did I just throw too
much yeah wait a minute we need a
mic
um really appreciate the talk and is
very Dev and I was trying to
decipher um
what you actually thought was the
relationship between capitalism and
media technology because in some ways
you're actually um suggesting that um
the need for let's say profit you know
Quaker Oats and U Mark zucken BG you
know drives these things but on the
other hand you're also kind of implying
that if we just get in touch with our
own Humanity our own Kronos um um those
larger systems capitalism don't actually
matter you know that that we can stop in
some way um so I'm trying to um I guess
push you on on what you think that
actual
relationship is whether this last
description I have which is we just get
in touch with the humanism and we can
stop it with you actually believe that
um the easiest way I can answer that is
um I got involved in the Rave scene did
you guys know what Rave was in the 19
late ' 80s early 90s I got involved in
the Rave scene and we thought this is
cool we're going to have no agenda it's
just like love connection you know we're
going to make this fractal and see where
it goes what we didn't understand was
the political economy in which this was
occurring that the most powerful thing
about the Rave was that it was
reclaiming public space but it was a
non-commercial activity people weren't
getting paid for music it was it was uh
uh it had certain boundaries around it
that made it special but we didn't know
what those boundaries were or we didn't
even we didn't know that they're what
what the other was so of course it ended
up being a commercialized thing in the
mall like everything else
um I feel that same sort of thing
happened to the net right that the net
originally was not just a government
project but it was in many ways a
problem for big business because people
were spending time doing something other
than production and consumption you know
the the scientists who were on on on
DARPA on arpanet they were sharing
recipes and talking about Star Trek
instead of doing the work that they were
supposed to do like the minute you
connected people through these
Technologies they started to talk and
even when people got fact machines they
used to send these awful blonde jokes to
each other and I always like why do
people think these are funny no they
just want an excuse to send something to
somebody else know so there was this um
there was this deep sort of social need
or or a a social Rehabilitation that was
going on to a a a television hypnotized
culture now had a medium through which
it could start to find other people on
the other side of it and and what I was
hinting at I think that if if if we want
a story for where it went wrong it was
we so badly wanted acknowledgement for
what we were doing like I was saying you
know would believe we do email no one
believed anything you know AT&T turned
down an opportunity to have the internet
for like a buck you they didn't want it
because they thought it wouldn't make
any money in that environment when
someone would come from a real company
or with money and say you know I like
what you kids are doing you know instead
of sitting in this garage making this
stuff like eating pizza and drinking
Coke come have a real company come do a
thing here's $10 million I remember I
used to get C s in the in the late '90s
when people saying just got $10 million
I don't know what to do with it we do
the whole thing we're just building it
on two laptops what do we do with the
money what just keep it I don't know
it's like there was just so much
uh somehow the the original uh dream or
mythology of building technologies that
would just help people communicate with
each other which is how everything was
built I mean most everything you use
today is just a spruced up version of
something that happened from MIT or
champagne or bana or one of the uh uh
one of the universities it was all
shareware know once we got that positive
reinforcement from business The
Narrative changed and it kind of became
oh this is they told us the story you
know if you drop out of
school and now instead of having these
teachers be your teachers now you've got
a venture capitalist being your teacher
he's about the same age he's had all
these experiences and he says no this is
the way you do it here's $10 million now
you've got to change your model so that
can pay back2 200 million instead of
this $5 million business $5 million a
year business you were going to do that
doesn't work because we only have a one
out of 100 shot with all these companies
so we need them to pay back 100 times
right it's a it's a it's actually a bad
even a bad VC model but it's the one
they use so kids are now they understand
we can't just have a successful company
we need a home run company so I watch so
many kids abandon uh uh abandon
technologies that would work and fulfill
the dream that they had had and be
profitable because they're not
profitable enough to satisfy the Home
Run equation so I feel like what we're
uh what we're not always acknowledging
is that we're developing our development
cycle is now built around some very
perverse and particular needs of venture
capital rather than developing for what
do people actually what do they need you
know and if we did that um you know I'm
all I'm all for digital technology
because of what it what it can provide
so I spend half my time trying to
convince you know it's not this is not
Marxism or anything I'm even trying to
convince business people that you got a
really bad model here there's a lot of
waste it doesn't work all your time what
if you you know invest in 20 companies
that can get doubles or singles and
triples rather than all home runs just
to sort of you know even show them the
numbers and go oh you know oh that's a
little bit better but when you've got
kids it's it's hard you know uh Evan uh
Evan Williams is a friend of mine since
back when he started blogger and he
needed like $300 to keep blogger going
back when you know it was it was and
then he sold it to Google and he
eventually made a whole lot of money on
that and some other things and
then after you have your first couple of
hundred
million and you do something like
Twitter might you think there's another
path other than okay you do it again now
I'm gonna go get Goldman Sachs get Smith
Barney do a thing get a thing go to the
and I saw him on the cover of the Wall
Street Journal with the under his face
4.3 billion is what he got on the IPO
day it's like how many hundred million
or billion or whatever do you need
before you say oh I don't need to use
that model to do my technology
development I can actually develop it in
another way so it's uh it's tempting
because people see this as you know each
one of these things as the next as the
next thing but what you actually find is
the best technological development
happens right after the crash you know
we got social media happened and blogger
happened after the dot crash because
people went oh okay not interesting
anymore and when it's not interesting is
when of course it's it's
interesting
yeah when you brought up the the Rave
era it it got me thinking in the last
couple years we've actually had some
moments of tech techological
Euphoria um Occupy Movement uh Arab
Spring if you look at for instance the
Middle East the the greatest
concentration of Twitter users is is in
Saudi Arabia quite shocking and and then
you start to think okay what is actually
Twitter doing for Saudi
Society is there um and while your
concentration this evening has been kind
of on the let's say the capitalist side
of Technology um it seems to me though
what there might be something else as
well that we should be talking about and
maybe you see there being a connection
to that and that is surveillance I mean
that's really the last year I think is
no one's really concerned too much about
capitalist system taking over their
their internet use but really that
they're being watched uh how do you see
that uh being incorporated into your
thoughts um it's interesting the for the
first 10 or 20 years years of Internet
style discoveries of invasions of our
privacy you know like the first one was
when I think it was who was it Lotus or
one of the companies had this CD that
was going around that it turned out it
had information on all the households in
America and people like oh my God
they've got information on my household
you it's like since 1912 there have been
direct marketers who've had little note
cards that know what's your property
value what's your thing it's just so
sometimes I'm I'm even with this last
with the Snowden thing I'm like Oh you
mean it took Snowden for you to realize
what's going on what did you think you
what did we think what did you think you
were doing don't people realize that
they are typing their private messages
on the
Internet it's on the internet you know
it's like this is this is more permanent
than if you etched it in the side of the
paron but this is and more distributed
and it's in it's there forever you know
how easy it is to do a simple search on
like your hard drive now all your emails
going to be that searchable pretty soon
it's so these are just text files this
is nothing and videos searchable so it's
like the
the the way I used to think about it to
make myself calm
was that the internet is a precursor
it's a test run it's a dry run it's a
it's a practice
for a world in which we're all going to
know what every body else is thinking
and doing anyway you know that was sort
of that's sort of the ravy mindset the
ravy mindset is that human beings are
evolving towards some kind of collective
organism you know we're pretending to do
it with technology and if technology
doesn't kill us first we might get to do
it as a as a society we might but what
about the invasion of privacy then if
everybody knows what everybody else is
thinking oh my gosh that's going to be
weird at least for the first few years
you know but I mean the fact is the sad
fact is they already do I mean have you
ever gone to one one of these shows with
a really good um lie detector guy you
know these guys that they can line up 10
people and talk to them and you and he
can show you how oh I saw she just
looked there therefore she's
uncomfortable that's she's the one who
did this he's the one who did that they
just can do it right and because what
they've done is taken subconscious and
subtle cues and brought them into
Consciousness so now they can they can
tell who's lying about what
well if he can do it it means that
subconsciously we're all doing it you
know there's no point in lying to
somebody because even if they think they
believe you deep down they know you're
giving them crap right they know
it so if that's if that's the case when
I look at surveillance culture I say oh
so we get surveillance culture on the
one hand and we're getting legalization
of pot and gay marriage on the other
hand why because if we know what
everybody's doing we see oh everybody's
smoking pot all these guys are doing gay
sex with each what are you going to do
this is what people do so you got to
start making those things it's a weird
little give and take that seems to go on
there it's it's freaky but
um the the interesting the more
interesting way to look at the
surveillance state
is Google comes along it's rising up it
looks like oh wow these are the kids
that are going to win right they're
going to win against Google and against
lyos and the other people who are trying
to index the world's knowledge and then
let's stick Eric Schmidt right in there
Eric Schmidt who's got just such
impeccable you know DOD Contracting
credentials I feel like that was the
moment that they said to Google either
directly or indirectly look we'll let
you run with this if we can have our guy
if we can have our back door if we can
be a part of this it would be dumb for
the government not to do that when it's
in that situation to say do you want
access to everybody's everything um and
yeah they have that the only time I get
uh you know concerned about it is in
matters of selective enforcement right
so if you're everybody's doing something
that's kind of illegal but every but
it's known by the system then that's
that's a big problem you know and the
other place I get worried about it more
worried about it is sort of algorithmic
prediction you know when and this is a
again it's a temporal Loop so that's why
it bothers me I'm really into time but
if you have algorithms using past
behavior of people people in your
statistical demographic in order to
figure out how to influence your future
decisions that's a really dangerous
combination let's say they figure out
from my past Behavior and the past
behavior of other people in my
algorithmic uh uh quintile uh that oh
there's an 80% chance he's going to go
on an unnecessary vegan
diet let's start marketing him vegan
stuff and that dangers of meat and
bloody pigs and all this imagery all the
stuff that we've tested and we know is
going to make it even more likely that
he's going to go on an unnecessary vegan
diet so they get me up from an 80%
chance and 20% chance of anomalous human
strange Behavior up to now 95% chance of
vegan diet and only 5% of anomalous
strange wonderful human behavior so as
we do that as we make ourselves you know
what we're trying to do is to make
people more consonant with predictive
algorithms rather than predictive
algorithms more consonant with people so
that's the kind of uh uh that's the kind
of privacy that I get concerned about
that's why I sometimes just do weird
stuff I'll look for stuff I don't need
on Amazon just to try to throw the damn
thing
off
yeah an amazing talk um I I find the
mentality that you're talking about very
real because I work as an engineering
Silicon Valley myself but I also think
that there are so many young people who
are not as stupid as people think and
very wellhe hearted um who go into
engineering who go into Silicon Valley
hoping to make a real impact real good
impact to the world but I think the
problem is that like people become numb
and and even if you are aware of the
problem it's really unclear there's no
guidance on like what are the things
that you can do to actually make that
situation better so I have that problem
myself but what would you say or or
think are something that something that
like we could do from the inside
well three three thoughts one Obama
spoke when he was running as if he was
answering that we are the change we've
been waiting for we are the thing we are
it but then he got into office and he
didn't facilitate us being the change
makers of our own blah blah blah blah
blah so we got occupied which was
actually occupy was the response to the
call that he put out when he ran even
though he wasn't connected to it at all
and probably was frightened by it but
occupy you know was was a postn
narrative political movement it was not
about Beginnings middles and ends that's
why CNN would go you know Aaron Bernett
out front what do you want what are your
demands we don't have demands well how
is this going to end we don't want it to
end you know it's like it didn't make
sense because they were playing they
were playing an infinite game that you
can't condense into the 9 seconds on CNN
it was much more internet open-ended uh
an open-ended kind of thing but it
doesn't play well in National media
right because National media is about
big one-size fits-all industrial generic
Solutions so that's why I think and it's
really it's sad in a way the only way to
do it is without glory and without size
know I get emails so many times all day
every day there's some in my email right
this minute from people saying oh I'm
going to create a social network that
will allow all of the world's activists
of this to get together and communicate
and share resources I'm going to create
a website that will serve as a clearing
house for all of the people who have the
sort of open and no what they're doing
is trying I the big the big they want to
do the thing you know where when we move
to human scale if that and that's what
I'm starting to believe it ends end up
being super local and super small you
know it's a different kind of a glory
right you do a great Community Theater
it could be as fun is doing a Broadway
play sometimes better because they don't
let you do the great play on Broadway
because they've got other things other
fish to fry or sometimes they do but
it's another story I was a theater
person still sad but should we tell who
your who your theater colleague was oh
yeah um uh Kelly easterling I was Wong
the water seller to her Shante in good
person of
Sichuan she's brilliant
actually she could have could have would
have should have I'm sure sure she did
fine she did
fine
but but in answer to your question what
I what I mean is is a small slow
incremental humano human locally scaled
change can still be modeled by other
people you know we can still but it's
where you're going to experience things
that's why I'm talking about bounded
investment as opposed to unbounded
investment if you're going to make an
investment invest in something that's
where you can kind of see it take form I
mean what do I need those numbers in a
Smith Barney account if I can invest
smartly in local businesses that I get
to eat at That Thai restaurant that I
just invested in my town is better now
my real estate goes up so once you have
a bounded um circulatory investment
instead of uh pie in the SK Universal
investment and that's not just in terms
of money but in terms of your your
activity you get to actually experience
some traction and you have to hope that
people are doing it in other places and
communicate with them and get uh uh get
encouragement from them but you can't
you can't wrap the whole thing
yeah inally irrelevant with um social
media
geogra geographical relationships are
seeming increasingly irrelevant because
of social media because social media
doesn't care about our Geographic
relationships they care about our
product loyalties right they don't care
they don't want me to have a
conversation with my nextdoor neighbor
about our car engines they want me to
have a conversation with another 2004
Mini Cooper owner even if they happen to
be in Iowa so that the only thing
connect ing us is the advertis quotient
right not the actual Community
engagement so no I I yet yes while
social media May mitigate the local I
don't use social media to engage with
people locally you know I I'm luckily
I'd say we right here can you imagine us
you know using it to talk now I mean
that was what my book program orb
program was about it was 10 commands for
a digital age and one of the first ones
was you know that that the the digital
technology is really good for
longdistance relationships really bad
for up close you know but it's it's
great it's great for that but no that
just because the bias of that technology
is against local conveniently so is uh
corporate capitalism is against local
right the Walmart doesn't want you to
have local affiliations they want you to
have uh National brand affiliations
doesn't mean uh that that all goes away
the interpersonal doesn't go away but
not all of your bounded regions have to
be geographical bounded regions you can
have a g a geographical bound or a a
bounded region with other people who are
in your in your working Guild right why
can't you have a guild of programmers a
guild of Architects a guild of this and
that's a non-l that's what associations
are and unions are and and that's those
are ways of creating uh of creating
bounds so no they don't have to be local
but local is a great starting point for
people who are disoriented it's like oh
where am I you know oh what's here been
so much of your daily experience is
spent in your actual body where you're
moving around I mean you guys know that
as as architect that you know where
people are matters um that it's it's
such an easy ready you know if you want
to make change you go outside it's like
well where who needs help you know it
kind of starts
it have we exhausted the questions
there's one more here let's let's let
him exhaust the it's kind of continuing
on your last point but as Architects we
have the potential to construct a sense
of place or of true physical place and
that's something that's been lost in
this preset put the mic up closer so we
can hear you it's been lost in this
presented Society and also in
contemporary architecture so do you see
place as kind of a radical idea yeah I
mean it's interesting I mean so I speak
as a the true architectural lay person
okay so don't yell at me um because
maybe they didn't mean any of this um I
was in uh Rockefeller Center last summer
and I was actually surprised walking
around feel I felt like Rockefeller
Center even though these are big
buildings with like offices it felt like
it was built for human beings it felt
human on some weird level something they
did with space made it feel like it was
a my human body felt oriented and okay
as it moved around and stuff that was
much much bigger than me as compared to
say going to to a lot of places with big
buildings and I feel like this little
dwarf nothing I felt okay whoever made
this thing understood that at least that
this is how big a body is so I thought a
little bit like Architects
can uh
uh can can create structures dedicated
to the human form and the human scale
rather than whatever Corporation they
were built to to praise you know we
don't have to just build the what that
clock for AT&T you know one of these
things which has nothing to do with my
little body it's it's there it's that so
right now the architecture in in my
world that people talk about is Google
is Google as this Cathedral and these
campuses and they don't feel to me
structured for the humans working in
them they feel like they are structured
for the some uh next stage of
Consciousness that they're going to
house within them you know they don't
they don't feel like Cathedrals that are
there
to have anything to do with how I feel
you know I feel like they're there at
best to maximize the efficiency of my of
my operation in the in the uh uh as a
worker so I I feel like there's this
there's a tremendous opportunity in
today's architecture to uh to start
thinking again about about I mean even
this is weird this is I mean nothing
against anybody if you built it this is
cool it's all cool it's all
cool but those things scare me as a
person they do they don't make me
comfortable they're just on little
sticks and they could fall and hurt me
you know so
um I don't know I think there's I think
there is a way just to ackowledge our
little bodies in your big buildings it
could help reverse some of that um some
of that
sensation thank you very much thank
you
[Music]